So we're currently looking at PlaySoundsViewController, and
what I've done here is that I've taken this pseudocode that we created in
the previous video and I've converted it into real code here.
Let me walk you through it.
By the way, all of this new code is also available in the instructor notes for
you to experiment with.
First I created a global object for AVAudioEngine.
And then I initialized it in viewDidLoad, right here.
So the step one in our pseudocode is done.
Let me scroll down a little bit to show you some of the other changes I
made in the playChipmunkAudio action.
Now remember that this is the method that actually runs,
when we press the Chipmunk button.
In here I called a new function called playAudioWithVariablePitch and
I passed in 1000 as the value of the pitch.
I defined this new function right here and within this function.
I make sure that I stop all audio before I play it back again.
Then I create an object for something called AVAudioPlayerNode.
So at this point the step two in the pseudo code is done.
The next step, step three, is to attach the audio player node we just created.
To the audio engine.
And I do that right here.
Whew!
We're making good progress.
All right, so the next thing for us to do is to create an object of
something called AVAudioUnitTimePitch, which I do right over here.
I updated the effects pitch to the argument this function was taking,
which in this case is going to be 1,000.
So our audio is going to have a really high pitch.
Okay, step four in our pseudo code is also done.
And then I attach this pitch effect.
To the audio engine so we're now done with step five.
Step six is about connecting the nodes to the audio engine.
So I used audio engines connect function to connect the audio player node
to the pitch effect and then the pitch effect to an output or the speakers.
So at this point step six and seven in our [INAUDIBLE] code are done.
Okay, finally I want to play the audio.
To do this I will use the audio player nodes.
Schedule file function.
Now, curiously enough this function schedule file takes in
an argument called file.
Which is going to be our audio recording.
And the type of this is AV audio file.
I must admit at this point that we haven't created any object with
this type previously.
The closest thing we have to this AV audio file,
is at the very top of our program, which is this received audio.
Now, this thing contains an NSURL to our recorded voice.
So, what we need to do is somehow convert the NSURL contained within
this to an AVAudioFile.
So, I googled to figure out that I could do this by creating a global variable
for AVAudioFile.
And, then initialize this in the ViewDidLoad.
Like that.
You will notice that I created this AVAudioFile by using
the receivedAudio's NSURL.
All right.
Now that I have the AVAudioFile, I can scroll back down, and
use the new AVAudioFile object, right here.
The other two arguments can be nil for now.
Now, I remember that the stack overflow page suggested that I
then start the audio engine, and finally play the audio player.
All right, it's time to run this code and see if it works.
I'm going to hit Record.
Won't you take me to.
Funky town.
And then when I hit the chipmunk button,.
[MUSIC].
It works.
All of this code is available in instructor nodes for you to play with.
If you have questions about any of the code over here,
please ask us on the discussion forum